[Musique]
oui pour en parler nous sommes avec
alain brunel députée pcf 16e
circonscription du nord bonsoir alain
bruneel merci d'être avec nous jérôme
bascher sénateurs l air de l'oise
bonsoir à vous également jérôme bascher
merci d'être avec nous alors un dîner
avec les chefs de groupe à l'assemblée
un déjeuner hier midi avec une dizaine
de personnes un conseil des ministres
par dessus le tout alors que le
gouvernement nous recommande depuis des
semaines de ne pas être plus de 6 ha
tamm et de respecter les gestes barrière
est ce qu'on peut dire que le président
n'a pas montré l'exemple
alain bruneel comme à l'air de penser
ces quelques français en tout cas on a
entendu sur cette antenne moi je pensais
pas fait parce que on vit une situation
depuis de mars et d confinement des
recommandations quand ça va pas on dit
que c'est les français qui font pas bien
qui n'aide pas les gestes barrières et
puis là on apprend que le public lui ne
respecte pas du tout les gestes barrière
c'est ça qui est dramatique parce qu'il
ya plus de confiance entre le citoyen et
le président de la république
c'est une grave question alors je
voudrais simplement dire aurait on a un
public devant le souhaite un prompt
rétablissement ainsi que tous ceux et
toutes celles qui sont aujourd'hui
atteints de la copie de 19 mais je
voudrais dire aussi au président que
lorsqu'il parle de virus qui circule un
peu partout qu'il faut faire attention
et qui nous donne ses recommandations la
scic ensemble des ministres et ben je
lui dis simplement que le virus lui il
s'invite partout quelle que soit la
situation sociale des citoyens mais y
compris à l'intérieur
alors effectivement depuis que
l'information était communiquée à la
mi-journée un beaucoup d'interrogations
beaucoup de pensées comme la vôtre alain
bruneel et beaucoup de railleries aussi
regardé par exemple tweet d'eric
coquerel député la france insoumise en
seine saint denis brunch tragique à
l'elysée
le sommet de l'état en isolement mais
que fait la police
annie responsable porteur du coc vide
apprend t-on organise un déjeuner de
plus de 10 personnes sur invitation
contraintes et pourtant sans protection
barrière rue du faubourg saint-honoré
autre réaction celle du député
bulykin d'eure-et-loir olivier marc l'ex
une pensée pour tous les restaurateurs
de france acquis emmanuel macron
interdit de travailler dix personnes à
dîner à l'elysée alors jérôme bascher
c'est vrai que voilà on l'a entendu avec
ces français on l'entend par ses
réactions de responsables politiques
d'élus il ya un côté voilà on nous
demande de faire des sacrifices et lui
ne le fait pas et ce qu'il serait d'une
certaine manière au dessus des lois ce
que c'est votre opinion également en
tout cas vous vous interrogez en ce sens
ça devant par exemple
et pourquoi les députés vient de
l'exprimer parfaitement lorsque vous
demandez à noël de moyenne plus de 6 1
lorsque le premier ministe d'y aller ses
amis pour aller chercher les enfants à
la sortie de l'école c'est possible
lorsque vous voyez bien que toute la
crédibilité de la parole gouvernementale
présidentielle après que le sénat a eu
rêver que jérôme ça le mot avait menti
sur les masques ce que les français
s'avèrent mais voilà le nom la personne
qui ment et qui manipule
oui bien que la confiance complète dans
les puissances gouvernante pour gérer
ces épidémies est catastrophique
je souhaite se voir comment collecter
alors été les choix tout seul sans
attendre que vides
je souhaite effectivement une maison la
république soit symptomatique
mais le symptôme c'est celui de ne pas
respecter l'est sa parole et c'est ça
qui m'inquiète le plus pour le président
la famille être 10 adam je le lis ces
coûts balle celle d'aujourd'hui coupable
je vous parlais des leçons échelons il
faut faire il va le faire
ça peut arriver à chacun d'entre eux moi
je sais que par exemple je serai sais
pas ce que je vais faire autrement
mais voilà c'est comme ça on essaye de
limiter au maximum tout nouvel an nous
ferons un juste ma famille point barre
dire à personne on peut donner l'exemple
et on peut
éviter c'est d'aider travail de fin de
période qu'ils sont heureux en fait le
président le gouvernement pourrait nous
répondre voilà on travaille pour l'état
pour les français c'est peut-être
différent de faire un repas de noël à 6
1 qu'est ce que vous pourriez répondre
pas différence quand on donne des
conseils aux citoyens et qu'on leur
demande d'être responsables et prudents
et qu'on lui ont alors dit écoutez les
fêtes de noël le couvre-feu ma nouvelle
enfin qu on sait très bien que c'est
important c'est très bien que vous avez
besoin de vous retrouver en fin d'année
c'est normal c'est la famille mais en
même temps on vous dit soie ivoire
puisque six ans mais on ne peut pas les
enfants genre pas et disent c'est pas
normal on peut pas accepter ça et moi je
suis d'accord avec ce qui était pisté
cuite et pardon tout à l'heure c'est de
dire pourquoi on demande aux français de
faire ça l ouest restaurateurs de fermer
à la culture de ne pas les sourires mais
c'est incompréhensible ça on peut pas
peut pas diriger le pays de cette
manière-là
et après on va dire aux gens car dès
aujourd'hui sur plus de 18 ans qui vient
de renforcer et on dit faut atteindre
5000 personnes pourquoi on atteint 5000
d'abord c'est parce qu'il n'ya pas assez
bien dans l'animation
c'est pour ça qu'on va atteindre 5000 et
qu'est ce qu'on a donné comme moyen âge
obito est-ce qu'on a ouvert comme l'y
rien du tout et ça continue comme si
rien n'était et nous on a droit
enfin et l'oreiller non encore dix ans
après je ne suis pas l'autre qui va
réapparaître des visions disons voilà
j'ai pas fait attention
est-ce qu'il va s'excuser auprès des
français c'est irresponsable moi je dis
quand je pense à dix responsables d'al
gouvernement aidé à présent la
république de dire aux gens vous devez
faire ça et lui même ne pas respecter
les consignes de l'ariège center alors
conséquences en cascade évidemment pour
l'exécutif jean castex testés négatifs
mais qui est quand même l isolement par
précaution ils auront également pour le
président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand richard perron qui a
fait beaucoup parler de lui aujourd'hui
parce qu'il a enfoncé le clou écouter
ses propos qui datent de fin octobre
dernier il ne suffit pas d'avoir peur
il faut aussi faire attention si nous
sommes malades demain c'est qu'à un
moment donné nous n'aurons pas fait
aussi attention que nécessaire chacun
d'entre nous doit être en vie
lens pour les autres et pour soi même
c'est quand on se relâche qu'on laisse
ce virus nous attaquer ce n'est pas une
question de faute c'est une question de
responsabilité pour les propos de
richard ferrand vous pensez que richard
ferrand appelé manuel micron pour lui
dire qu'il n'avait pas fait attention
que c'était un petit peu relâché jérôme
bascher je ne sais pas il peut arriver à
tout le monde et pour que les deux
énormément énormément et dans des
positions variées et lui comme moi
prenons les transports en commun je
suppose que comme son collègue il prend
le train pour venir harry et les bons
défis dans les gares du nord je vais
suis aussi gare du nord et laurent le
verrou et ont beaucoup de gens dont nous
a semblé se toute la journée moi j'ai dû
voir des mères on était masqué et à
distance dans les pieds ça irait mais
enfin il faut rencontrer les gens ne
peut pas de panique donc les gestes
barrières ils sont nécessaires pour
éviter une propagation trop rapide mais
ça n'empêche pas tout ça empêche à tous
donc le visant la république bien
normalement un voie des stands de
personnes dans ses fonctions et le monde
continue à vivre et à la vie voit donc
il sait bien qui sent le cul mais c'est
vrai que la révélation de ce dîner et
fait vraiment tâche au moment où tous
les français se privent moi j'aimerais
me dire ça fait plusieurs mois que je
les ai reçus personne âgée chez moi un
paquet d'avants qui habite à côté
personnes dont il ya un moment où
j'étais j'ai pas me plaindre mais il ya
des gens très isolé de ce faux et qu'ils
font fort des personnes malades et on a
le droit de recevoir on nous l'a dit on
essaye de faire les efforts et vous
voyez bien que le président de la
république a demandé des efforts
français qui les a félicité tous les
quinze jours à la télévision pour leurs
efforts et bien lui lit - jeu reasoner
non non là il ya vraiment un problème
vous pouvez pas faire confiance à
quelqu'un qui vous demande sans arrêt à
faire des efforts comme animateur aux
collègues députés aux sportifs
aux artistes paul et puis vous de vous
exagérez cet effort il vient s'exonérer
cet effort pas chance tout de suite il
est où vous avez dans le mode est à vous
faire très attention et je ne sais pas
si je suis moi-même exempt de tout
reproche et donc faisons bien attention
les uns les autres
alain bruneel selon vous est ce qu'il y
aura un impact politique sur la
présidente des manuels macron parce que
c'est vrai que finalement ce n'est pas
le seul un dirigeant on les signes
depuis la mi-journée donald trump boris
johnson johnson araud c'est pas le seul
à avoir attrapé le coronavirus emmanuel
macron il y aura des conséquences selon
vous en france je sais pas s'il a des
conséquences que je affirmer c'est que
la confiance n'irait plus entre les
citoyens et le gouvernement
après c'est des citoyens qui décideront
s'il ya des conséquences sur la
politique du croyant d'art public et
puis du gouvernement par contre là il
montre pas l'exemple et c'est ça qui est
important c'est que lorsqu'on est
président on lorsqu'on est responsable
on collègues il l'a dit à quelques
instants on a effectivement rencontre
des gens dans des réunions on tient nos
distances
on n'est pas à l'abri ça c'est clair
mais on fait extrêmement attention
moi je pense aussi que nous on fait
attention et aussi les citoyens font
extrêmement intentions les citoyens sont
des gens intelligents il ya une force
extraordinaire à travers les citoyens
après tandis way des testeurs par six
les quotas mais la majorité
après ça pose quand même la question est
ce qu'on est sur le bon chemin
au niveau du de la cobi 19 passes
colorent les vaccins qui m'arrive est la
plus d'un million ici avant la fin de
l'année une première première phase mais
est ce que c'est le bon moyen
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas dû faire comme
d'autres pays confiné pendant quelques
semaines pour éviter que le virus
circule et faire le choix de sauver des
vies au lieu que le ici de faire le
choix de sauver l'économie
jérôme bascher ça pose aussi évidemment
la question de la sacralisation de la
fonction on ne compte plus les
présidents de la république français qui
ont caché leurs pépins de santé du plus
grave au plus bénins d'ailleurs est ce
que vous laissez au moins vous concédez
au moins et même
macron qu'il y a eu une sorte de
transparence sur sur cet épisode
aujourd'hui tous ceux qui sur les
réseaux par le complot sur le co ville
etc
ça va permettre de tuer ses idées au
moins je l'espère que tous les
complotistes en tous genres pense que
c'est à un faux seins faux sujet ce
virus
bon la présidente lui qui est touchée
que n'importe quel humain il est
touchant et ce n'est pas intouchable il
est
j'espère trop sévèrement je l'espère
pour le riz parce que c'est quand même
bien dans le deux roues d'alterner
spécialité on a eu je rappelle le
nucléaire que le président de la
république soit au rêve à peu près dans
un état santé et de capacité le plus
total bon et s'il va s'appuyer
peu importe ce que je veux dire c'est
que d'importer qui peut être touchée et
que tout le monde doit faire attention
et on a c'est normal que les différences
merci les gaullistes et les commissures
ça sera au chai euros il faut résister
ensemble mais sur l'économie ça aussi
importante a fait revivre et c'est vrai
que j'ai constaté ces derniers jours à
paris que dans les magasins par exemple
il y avait des foulées incroyable et il
ne faudra pas s'étonner qu'il y ait
troisième bague je le dis vraiment
simplement ce n'est pas possible
autrement ce n'est pas possible
autrement cela est inquiétant créera
d'autres soucis d'autres totaux épreuve
mais j'aimerais bien avoir un qualité le
navire qui demande beaucoup d'humilité
qu'ils soient effectivement exemplaires
vous venez de mettre le doigt sur sur le
problème aujourd'hui est ce que quand on
verra emmanuel macron nous parler de
guerre à la télévision nous dire de
faire des efforts parce que s'il ya une
troisième vague ça veut peut-être dire
qu'il y aura un nouveau confinement dans
ces conditions comment demander
justement aux français d'accepter
renouveau confinement est ce que ça
voilà où ça n'a rien à voir peut-être
alain bruneel après s'il ya une
troisième vague qui risque qui se
dessine de toute façon malheureusement
on ne souhaite pas qu'elle ait lieu mais
tout le monde dit qu'aujourd'hui on va
sur la troisième faille dès que j'ai pas
de fin d'année risque aussi d'entraîner
la troisième il va falloir prendre des
décisions et quand le président de la
république par exemple dans le cadre de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
propose un état sanitaire est en état
d'urgence sanitaire
nous votons nous votons donc shangai
donne son avis là dessus donc moi je
pense que les citoyens sont responsables
alors que le président de la république
ils disent après comment on va faire sur
la troisième bail qui à disposition
qu'ils soient prises effectivement elles
seront prises
parce que les gens quand je parle
d'intelligence que l'été des gens sont
des gens intelligents et savent très
bien qu'ils n'ont pas prendre de risque
pour eux aussi pour leurs familles ils
sont déjà aussi malheureux comme ça
quand ça se passe pour un mandant
famille lorsqu'ils peuvent pas non plus
assisté à un enterrement
lorsqu'ils peuvent pas être auprès de
leurs proches le cas lors celui-ci
malheureusement décèle par le coït bon
je pense qu'après ces quelques à une
troisième vague les gens ils vont y vont
obliger n'était façon si un confinement
sont obligés de le suivre alors que soit
le président pas le président mais le
président avec ce qui a dit le manque de
confiance aujourd'hui ce qui a été fait
également appuyé touché par la copie 19
astique certainement de gouvernement
les gens vont quand même écouter et donc
vont essayer aussi aujourd'hui de faire
en sorte que remplissent pas les
hôpitaux qui a moins il ya moins de deux
personnes touchées c'est un peu ça donc
confiance pas confiance
les gens m'ont faire automatiquement
pour vous
va certes non mais écoutez moi je sais
surtout que le sang soit efficace ce don
est qu'il ait de conséquences
secondaires
serrières des choses car c'est aussi
dans l'histoire soit un entraînement
fois dallas a que résidera le vrai
espoir je ne crois plus beaucoup aux
solutions du gouvernement et aujourd'hui
on n'a pas de crédibilité de ceux qui
nous dirigent
donc il faut essayer de recouvrer un peu
de croyance dans la science et de la
médecine
pour l'instant je comprends le
scepticisme des français moi je vous le
dis très sincèrement j'étais dans les
tous premiers vaccinés contre la grippe
à la fin de ma vie pour écouter liés aux
gens vaccinez vous convient pour éviter
d'avoir le double effet cosy de grives
là j'avoue que je ne suis pas du tout à
fait prioritaire mais je rembourse
inquiètes des conséquences secondaires
forcément sur ce vaccin des fils
espérait vraiment qui fonctionne qu'on
arrive et qu'on aura pas la fascination
commenté mme à ce qu'on a raté le
testing
quand arrêter le confie emmanuel macron
confina à la long terme cette résidence
des présidents français proche de
versailles
merci à vous deux alain bruneel et
jérôme bascher d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france